cuando observamos el cosmos buscando
vida extraterrestre mucha gente busca
signos de agua en los satélites o
planetas y eso es porque la vida tal
como la conocemos depende del agua para
entender eso analicemos algunas
propiedades del agua
aquí tenemos moléculas de agua esto tal
vez sea un repaso para ustedes cada
molécula de agua tiene un átomo de
oxígeno y está unido a dos hidrógenos
entonces este es un hidrógeno y éste es
otro hidrógeno
ahora este enlace es covalente lo que
significa que el oxígeno comparte
electrones con cada uno de los átomos de
hidrógeno pero el oxígeno es más electro
negativo y eso es solo una forma
elegante de decir que aunque esos
electrones se comparten pasarán más
tiempo cerca del oxígeno que de los
hidrógenos una forma de pensar en esto
es que al oxígeno le gusta acaparar más
electrones que al hidrógeno y dado que
los electrones pasarán más tiempo cerca
del oxígeno que cerca del hidrógeno y
debido a que es una molécula angular con
los hidrógenos de un lado de la molécula
lo que sucede es que en el lado donde
está el oxígeno es decir donde los
electrones pasan más tiempo podemos
decir que este lado tiene una carga
parcial negativa esta letra griega delta
minúscula significa carga parcial
negativa por lo tanto las partes donde
se encuentran los hidrógenos tienen una
carga parcial positiva entonces como
puedes ver la molécula de agua no tiene
una carga formal sino que tiene una
carga parcial en cada lado
así que es una molécula polar entonces
pueden imaginarse qué sucede cuando
juntamos un montón de moléculas de agua
bueno el lado parcialmente positivo de
la molécula de agua es decir donde se
encuentran los hidrógenos será atraído
por el lado parcialmente negativo de
otra molécula de agua serán atraídos y a
eso se le conoce como puente de
hidrógeno
y puedo seguir dibujando esto esto es
parcial positivo esto parcial negativo
se atraen este oxígeno es atraído por
este hidrógeno y este oxígeno es atraído
por este hidrógeno de modo que este
puente de hidrógeno es el que le da al
agua muchas de las propiedades que la
hacen tan especial que hasta donde
sabemos permite que la vida sea posible
la vida tal como la conocemos necesita
un entorno fluido las cosas se mueven y
chocan entre sí cuando la temperatura y
las condiciones son apropiadas estos
puentes de hidrógeno permiten que el
agua esté en esta forma líquida donde
son lo suficientemente fuertes como para
que el agua permanezca unida pero a la
vez son débiles con lo que permiten que
las moléculas de agua fluyan entre sí y
no solamente provee un buen ambiente
fluido también es un buen solvente
el agua a menudo se conoce como el
solvente universal solvente universal
pero hay que hacer una aclaración aunque
mucha gente dice que es un solvente
universal eso no significa que disuelva
todo el agua en su estado líquido
disuelve más cosas que cualquier otro
solvente que conozcamos pero hay
moléculas que no puede disolver bien las
sustancias que el agua disuelve bien son
cosas como las moléculas polares o
aquellas sustancias que tienen una carga
por ejemplo cuando se disuelve cloruro
de sodio en el agua un ión de sodio es
positivo tiene una carga positiva y
entonces puedes imaginar que es atraído
por el oxígeno de las moléculas de agua
se disuelve bien
y las cosas que no tienen carga no se
disuelven bien en agua pero aunque hay
ciertas cosas que no se disuelven en
agua es buena para la vida
más adelante en biología estudiaremos
las vi capas de fosfolípidos donde
encontrarás estas moléculas un extremo
es hidrofílico lo que significa que se
siente atraído por las moléculas de agua
y los otros extremos son hidrofóbicos lo
que significa que no se sienten atraídos
por las moléculas de agua muchos
biólogos evolucionistas creen que estas
propiedades de tener un lado hidrofílico
y un lado hidrofóbico permitieron que
estas moléculas comenzaran a acumularse
en las membranas formando eventualmente
estas membranas esféricas que podrían
ser los recipientes para la vida celular
temprana ahora otra propiedad del agua
que la hace muy buena para la vida es su
alta capacidad calorífica a veces
escucharás que la gente dice que el agua
tiene un calor específico alto el calor
específico es la cantidad de energía
necesaria para elevar un grado celsius
un gramo de agua
y tal vez te preguntes qué importancia
tiene eso para la vida bueno muchas
formas de vida solo pueden existir en un
cierto rango de temperaturas de modo que
si fuera realmente fácil elevar la
temperatura del agua a temperaturas muy
altas o muy bajas rápidamente sería
difícil que la vida existiera dentro del
agua o incluso que la vida hubiera
existido inicialmente en el agua una
idea relacionada con esto es que el agua
también tiene un alto calor de
vaporización hablaremos más sobre esto
en otros vídeos pero esto habla de
cuánta energía necesita el agua para
pasar de su forma líquida a su forma
gaseosa y esto ha resultado útil en
muchas formas de vida como una manera de
enfriamiento donde el enfriamiento por
evaporación puede eliminar el calor de
un organismo para que no se
sobrecaliente otras propiedades del agua
que también son importantes incluyen la
cuestión
y la adhesión la cuestión es la
propiedad de las moléculas de agua de
atraer a otras moléculas de agua y lo
viste aquí con los enlaces de hidrógeno
pero cuando lo miras en macro escala
verás cómo se forman gotas de agua todos
han visto gotas de agua o gotas de rocío
estas gotitas no podrían formarse si no
fuera por la cuestión del agua e incluso
una gota puede ser el entorno en el que
pueden vivir miles de microorganismos la
adhesión es la propiedad del agua en
donde puede adherirse a otras
superficies es posible que hayas visto
esto en un tubo de ensayo de vidrio
donde parece que el agua se adhiere a la
parte superior de las paredes de vidrio
y eso se debe a la polaridad de las
moléculas de vidrio del tubo de ensayo
pero esta propiedad junto con la
cohesión es la que permite que el agua
transporte nutrientes por ejemplo desde
las raíces de un árbol hasta la parte
superior de un árbol estas propiedades
también actúan en nuestros propios vasos
sanguíneos cuando llegas a los vasos
sanguíneos que son realmente pequeños
los
a pilares y se les llama capilares
porque tienen la acción capilar del agua
que se debe a su cuestión y su adicción
una última propiedad del agua y esta no
es una lista muy detallada es que es
menos densa que un sólido otra forma de
pensar en esto es que el hielo que es
agua sólida es menos denso que el agua
líquida ahora podrías estar pensando
porque es importante para la vida bueno
imagina uno de los ambientes en los que
pensamos que surgió la vida por primera
vez si imaginas un estanque esta es la
sección transversal del estanque si el
hielo es más denso que el agua líquida y
para muchas sustancias en ese caso una
forma sólida tiende a ser más densa
entonces qué pasaría
si hace frío aquí en el aire digamos en
invierno entonces esta parte se
congelaría pero luego a medida que se
volviera más denso se hundiría hasta el
fondo justo aquí entonces la siguiente
superficie de agua se congelaría y se
hundiría hasta el fondo y luego con el
tiempo el lago completo o el estanque
completo se congelaría y la vida no
podría existir allí porque cuando el
agua se congela rompe las estructuras
ligadas a la membrana tal como la
conocemos y eso no sería adecuado para
la vida pero como el hielo es menos
denso que el agua lo que normalmente
ocurre es que esa capa superior se
congela y luego se congelará a medida
que las cosas se pongan cada vez más
frías pero tiene un entorno completo
donde la vida puede seguir prosperando
incluso cuando el aire es mucho más frío
de lo que es adecuado para la vida y
debido al alto calor específico del agua
la variación de temperatura en esa agua
va a ser mucho menor que la variación de
temperatura fuera del agua ya sea en el
aire
esto es solo una introducción pero
espero que te haga apreciar el agua un
poco más y recuerda lo que he dicho en
otros vídeos en su mayoría estamos
hechos de agua una forma de pensar en
esto es que cada uno de nosotros está
formado por trillones de células
compuestas principalmente por agua y que
existen en un ambiente en donde
predomina el agua se coordinan entre
ellas y eventualmente logran una
complejidad tan grande que conforman a
un ser como cada uno de nosotros hasta
el próximo vídeo